all right Gary I'm gonna bring you on
okay
good morning good morning oh you you
press live okay yeah you said I could
press yeah I know I know all right fair
enough uh good morning everyone you see
there we go
we are live again on t with garyvee I
just want to say what's up to everybody
hope everybody's been super well first
and foremost let's definitely get uh
everybody in all the live platforms to
say what's up and say good morning and
tell me where they're from what part of
the world uh
and we're excited Justin Ramona Deb and
Nicole and Marco and Tom we've got all
sorts of characters lined up for
questions today with tea with garyvee is
finally back
on this Gloomy Tuesday Morning in New
York City it is a Gloom Fest outside my
office here uh there's some gloom and
doom amongst the New York Jets Nation as
well that's got me extra gloomy as well
but uh being with all of you is a real
treat and the Q a show that I love so
much to you with garyvee is now back and
uh I'm excited to be with all of you and
so uh dust are you here you feeling good
yes sir look I can actually wave from
over your right shoulder
um right there not exactly the covet
Stitch when we were far away from each
other uh great audience so are we dust
real quick are we live on all I see I
see LinkedIn in there I see YouTube in
there
um I see Facebook in the comments
Instagram and Tick Tock as well um
well yeah
yeah
you know they announced it yeah
the office is getting rebooted so we
have double mugs this morning
a double marked life look at this double
mud but this one matches my sweatshirt
type I didn't even plan that so I like
it all right dust let's get into the
show q a for the next hour
straight here on t with garyvee
uh first up we'll have Nicole
Nicole good morning or I should say good
evening from Melbourne Australia which
is where I'm from I Love It Well welcome
and thank you for uh being the first
question on the reboot of the show how
are you thank you thank you so much for
having me I'm very excited I'm a bit
nervous but I'm so excited so far away
so something that you've always said
which has really resonated with me is
being the bigger person is always right
and it's something that um you've
definitely like reiterated a lot and
there's something I've tried to apply to
my own life yeah how do you be the
bigger person without rewarding bad
behavior
uh by delivering Candor you know being
the bigger person doesn't mean look the
other way
being the bigger person is having the
capacity to not counter bad behavior
with more bad behavior yeah good
behavior is empathy and candor
bad behavior is someone does something
evil to you and you spend all your time
trying to be evil to them someone does
something disrespectful to you and you
want to be disrespectful to them someone
does something to you and you're
spiteful and try to get them back so
being the bigger person is not being
complacent
and being and looking the other way and
burying it and building resentment or
being a pushover this goes back to nice
guys finish last they don't finish last
they finished first because what's
happening in this scenario is when
someone is doing quote-unquote bad
behavior and not your subjective bad
behavior because you're selfish about
something no we survey all the thousands
of people that are watching this right
now and ask people
you know what they think
you know and they all agree with you
that bad behavior that requires I saw
somebody put radical Candor I think it
requires kind Candor you know empathetic
sympathetic compassionate like you're
not in a good place
um and we are here to try to
address that you know and so you know to
me being the bigger person is having the
mental and emotional strength to go
above the other person's Behavior
but also being able to protect yourself
so for me being the bigger person is I'm
going to try to give I'm going to try to
give I'd love to do the right thing here
but there is always a Tipping Point
there's always a time to fire to cut out
to break up
but the key is
not being triggered in return I promise
you for all the people that are watching
right now if you counter bad behavior
with bad behavior you're not in a great
place
you yourself are not in a great place
and I know this to be true this is
perfect timing my New York Jets are
having a devastating season
and at jet games I'm incapable of the
things I'm speaking about here because
I'm in a bad place I'm in Full Tilt I'm
frustrated I have 40 Years of
unhappiness and in that mindset in that
perspective I'm the worst version of
myself and I'm not kidding about this I
think people are tongue-in-cheek think
I'm being tongue tongue-in-cheek I am
able to understand
frustration losing unhappiness not
feeling in control
um all the emotions that people feel
about politics feel about relationships
feel about bosses feel about work feel
about governments
the only place I'm able to feel that is
being a sports fan of a specific team
and so I'm aware of what it feels like
to not have the capacity to be the
bigger person or put things in
perspective and I know it you know for
me I'm very happy that the one place
that I don't have that emotional control
is something as silly as an American
football game but people bring that same
energy to real life and that's something
I like talking about and that's the
answer to your question do not confuse
being the bigger person with complacency
and enablement of bad behavior
yeah
yeah very true are you what do you deal
are you willing to go further what are
you dealing with right now in this exact
scenario or is it a little too private
at this point
that's fine um probably a few different
aspects of my life I think with friends
that's probably where it gets more
personal
um and we're friends and this is someone
who struggled with cancer his whole
career and life it's about telling them
and by the way I had a conversation this
weekend with a friend about it I've been
able to really build this weekend I told
one of my friends ironically at the Jets
game about something that happened the
prior week and it's huge I wasn't able
to seven years ago
deliver with calmness and kindness
Candor I would just let it sit yeah and
that to your point that would enable
more bad behavior which led to
resentment which would lead to fraction
right
yeah you could deliver the news and you
could do it nicely
yeah and then by the way be prepared for
them to counter because they're not
ready to hear that with more Venom and
then you gotta be even nicer being the
bigger person yeah I think that's why I
understand Sarah that you're not ready
to hear this I love you but this one
thing you do is hurting my feelings
yeah I think that's where I get to be
it's key it's I'm telling you it's
Candor okay but it's kind Candor Nicole
yeah empathy
understanding that there's a bigger
thing happening there
why they're doing bad behavior that
their mom taught heard that bad behavior
her dad something in her real life maybe
people become envious and jealous
because they're hurt
you know maybe you're in a good
relationship and they're not like you
know there's a million things out there
anyway thanks for being on the show
thank you so much hope to see me Monday
let's keep going Dustin
Gary vaynerkel my man how you doing
brother
Justin I've been better my football
season is over before October 1st I did
not anticipate that with this
summer of hype well as a Packer fan I
get the pain so
and with your Star Quarterback going
down I feel that pain as well because
obviously it took him from me
adjusted you did you did you watch Aaron
Rodgers win that Super Bowl for you as a
Packer fan when you were a kid
um back in 2000 2011 right yeah I did
that was that was the uh I just joined
the Navy at that point was super excited
I was a you know Big Time Packer fan we
just won I thought we're gonna go on to
years of success and just just so you
know you don't feel like
Super Bowl you have tons of success with
Aaron I have the Jets are the longest
Team without a playoff appearance in all
four major sports I've watched every
play since 1982. it is my one passion
that matters to me at any kind of level
you and I you do not feel my pain yeah
well I'm sure it's going to get better
Gary He's got to stick with it it's
gonna get better I get it go ahead
brother
yeah absolutely and this is an honor man
I don't know if you remember but I was
actually on your call-in show uh
garyvee240 back in 2017. so
now we're in person I'll be there so
real quick for all the people that are
watching and asking and figuring trying
to figure out how these incredible
people got on the show they followed
team garyvee's account on Instagram and
thus they were able to pay attention was
there anything else we did
update so it was just an Instagram thing
thank you uh going forward we're going
to take questions from my text messaging
platform in the US so that's two one two
nine three one five seven three one use
the hashtag t with garyvee when you ask
when you text me a question dust you got
to be on the ones and twos I know you
got this nice fancy design here I don't
know how you're gonna do the pop-up but
you'll figure that out and then for
everyone International you can DM
teamgaryvee at teamgaryvee on Instagram
when you DM them with a question you can
use hashtag t with garyvee if you want
to be on the show as we are now bringing
this show back uh Justin go ahead so uh
kind of a two-part question um as a
startup business
um I do War treatment so we're very
heavily inventory based
um and especially at the beginning as
you know dollars matter and especially
when your inventory base a lot of that
money really goes towards equipment and
a little bit of marketing so in that
those early you know first one to two
year stages with limited cash flow how
would you one allocate dollars to you
know SEO Smo traditional marketing signs
door knocking Word of Mouth
um and then the second part of that
question is when you were you know
starting you know vaynermedia and you
didn't really have the the garyvee brand
yet yeah um how did you really acquire a
good talent kind of in those early days
yeah uh dust make sure on the thing you
got scrolling there It also says use
hashtag teamgaryvee because I get a ton
of texts there anyway and I want to be
able to make sure me and the team can
find them uh look when you don't have a
lot of capital and you want to spend
some of it on marketing you've got to
figure out what
um really works best for you so if you
know how to do sem or SEO great if you
know how to do social media content
great if you know how to hire some kids
to do door knocking and give them a
percentage of every lead great there is
no right
way of marketing there's a right way of
marketing for you are there right ways
of marketing overall of course do I
believe that social media content
outperforms you know other marketing
Styles sure but if you're not good at it
then all of a sudden you've got a
problem as far as the garyvee stuff with
the talent I hired friends and family
yeah you know the first five seven eight
employees were AJ's friends and Matt
Cinema who worked for me at vane at Wine
Library and then answering some tweets
of people that were willing to work for
internships like Nate Schroeder and John
Troutman and Joe whitmarsh these people
basically work for minimum wage you know
you know people forget about my story
you know not only did I not own Wine
Library not only did my dad not give it
to me my dad also didn't pay me much
yeah by the time I was 34 I didn't start
vaynermedia in somebody else's
conference room for free because I was
cool or I thought it was cool it was
because I didn't have any money
right and so so we I don't think people
scrap enough like they waste like people
start a company and then they go get an
office and it's 2023 and you can do it
at home
right and people go look for talent
instead of grooming Talent a lot of
times the talent are your friends and
family and kids you went to high school
with and things of that nature that you
know don't have better options and
you're going to build them up you're
going to train them up
oh yeah no I and that and that makes
perfect sense we've been kind of doing
that so my thing is we we started really
you know super cheap and we're you know
getting leads in and you know now we're
getting some cash flow in the biggest
thing is I obviously want to to execute
on the place that's going to bring more
return on that money and I've been doing
the problem just the problem is the
return on the money is the variable of
where's the best opportunity but also
what are you best at basketball players
get paid way more than hockey players
but if you're incapable of playing
basketball and you're and you can get to
the NHL playing hockey you need to play
hockey so the question really
becomes you as the leader and this is
for everybody I'm watching for Rima for
Omar Lara for Denver floor XX for PDG
for Carla Brian for Mass Growers all the
people I see in the comments right there
yes I believe in social media content
yes I believe in uh that over everything
right now as an Arbitrage
but if you're better at hiring people to
door knock or if you're or if you got
trained for 10 years on SEO and sem you
have to allocate a good percentage to
that
while learning how to do social media
organic content in parallel with 20 to
40 of your energy it's the allocations
right no that makes sense because we
we've been trying to kind of tackle that
because we actually got a big hit on
Tick Tock we actually blew us up pretty
quickly
um so we're really focusing on on the
social side but also you know jab jab
you know jab right hook I don't want to
monetize too soon on that so it's that
that balancing active don't forget that
don't forget the right look though yeah
get the balance but if you post four
times a day or three times a day instead
of once every four days you can throw
more right hooks gotcha and I gotta go
to the next one Justin I apologize
Dr JP great to see you back here as well
glad to be back with all of you
Deb how are we oh my gosh I'm out of my
mind I'm so excited how are you I'm well
okay I'm so happy to be here
um I know nothing about the Jets
okay okay okay uh so I'm 51. yep and um
started my Instagram with zero followers
when I stopped drinking alcohol and I
broke up with your dad uh and 20 last
day of 2020. that's right what's that I
said if that's right for you it makes me
so happy it's been great okay so I've
grown my Instagram to a little bit over
a hundred thousand followers in under
three years and I'm just building my
mocktail mom business and so my question
for you is if you were
um building a mocktail business
basically I I just love to encourage
others that the Fun's not over that
there's still good things to drink and
so what would you advise me to do to
scale my business a couple things tea
with Tosh uh I see you a long
questionnaire I'm gonna get the team to
try to connect with you because I'm
really excited about the twitch Mafia
everyone on Twitch please say hello in
the comments right now uh big shout out
to Twitch Mafia Deb it is content
content content look I think you're on
Trend I think mocktails will continue to
grow at scale okay at scale
for quite a while here and I think it's
a huge movement I think gen Z and Jen
Alpha will drink less or less often yeah
I see a future marketplace where I see a
ton of people
mocktailing Monday through Thursday yeah
and maybe cocktailing on the weekend
yeah so I think you know in general I
think you're on a massive Trend Sid just
threw up your Instagram for me right I
think you know the biggest thing let me
just see when when was this posted for
example if I post a day ago was posted I
don't think you're posting enough you
know I was able to go five or six posts
back on Instagram and it says six days
ago I think two posts a day on Instagram
is a minimum you know I think two
different ones or slightly different
versions of the same thing on Tick Tock
with a different thumbnail with a
different audio overlay because they're
slightly different yeah YouTube shorts
more more yeah and then the
encouragement will just come from the
content yeah you know like because I
posted more for a decade more business
people are willing to be nice yep I see
that every day dad every day I'm in the
world yeah I was in Utah this weekend La
Saudi Arabia Australia
um where else have it been Brazil
there's not a PL and then every day in
my email and DMS thank you Gary for
giving me permission to be nicer even
though I'm trying to make a trillion
dollars yeah that is a byproduct of the
content you will encourage the behavior
with the content yeah you know
communication dictates people's
perspective yep okay and so what I'm
noticing is just more opportunity for
more content okay you know you know yeah
I think I think it and I think finding
ways to do that I'm doing tea with
garyvee for more content absolutely yep
I start a podcast yep I started my
Instagram yep start a podcast yeah so
YouTube shorts is a monster for you okay
I would look at Google Trends and Google
to see what people are searching in
mocktail and then I would title your
YouTube shorts that way so they show up
when people search them for YouTube
YouTube and Google for that matter
YouTube shorts Instagram Tick Tock I
think linkedin's a monster For You
especially if you make Monday mocktails
where you talk about like hey you're
working this week you're on LinkedIn
instead of drinking on Tuesday night
make this mocktail at home you know I I
think there's an enormous opportunity
for you okay okay okay thank you so much
I love you so much Richard Richard
blackwood's absolutely right oh no he
didn't say that uh Sean why um is I'm a
huge fan for everybody who's watching to
do events just to film it just for the
content so things like that let's keep
it going
Snoop Dogg is watching Snoop Dogg thank
you for watching on the plane my guy one
of the great entrepreneur forget about
the iconic hip-hop artist one of the
great entrepreneurs in our world Snoop
is watching Derek don't it up
I I won't it up Gary uh first of
all thank you for letting me uh come on
ask my question uh a couple of months
ago we launched a mascot for my company
uh we started doing uh Comic Cons and
Live Events and stuff we do progressing
graphic design uh I know you're a big
pro wrestling fan huge so uh and I know
you've been keeping up with what I've
been doing the last couple years but we
decided to do a mascot because we're
starting to do Live Events and Comic
Cons
um so what would what do you think is
the best way for me to Market this
mascot
um I don't have like a full mascot
outfit yet but I do have a good
backstory companies going on 11 years I
really credit a lot of the success to
what you've done in your content over
the years uh so like I said a little bit
of insight on it's it's I was kind of
paying attention to be friends because
that is kind of a company mascot how was
the mascot
sit and form right now do you have a 2D
rendering a 3D rendering do you have a
puppet do you have a costume do you have
a do you have an emote video do you have
a a filter that's VR excuse me AR do you
how do you have the mascot right now uh
right now I have it in uh 2D I'm
actually getting 3D figures printed out
uh we went the cheaper route with the 3D
printing so I have a batch of those in
in the works I have a couple different
t-shirt designs I've rebranded the
website I think the number one way to
get a mascot going is in physical form
so you know if you look at what Duolingo
is doing
on social full disclosure we work with
Duolingo in Latin America I believe
um the Duolingo mascot on Tick Tock do
you know anything about that
uh take that note okay so I want you to
Google I want you to Google
I want you to Google doolingo mascot
Tick Tock and I want you to spend the
day looking at what they're doing I
would spend a couple thousand dollars to
make a full mascot outfit
so that you could have someone
be the mascot in as much content as
possible that is the quickest way to
build awareness around a mascot
gotcha that's a great advice I was
actually looking into the costumes not a
cheap thing but it's definitely going to
be worth it it's not it's not a cheap
thing but it is the answer and so I'd
rather you sell three thousand dollars
worth of stuff that's in your house
right now on eBay and Facebook
Marketplace this is where people get
up they're like carrying all the
money I'm like the money's sitting in
the garbage in your house the clothes
you don't wear the stuff in your
basement stuff in your attic right
it is it is and it
that pulled to be like is this worth
more than the stuff in the house and it
always is in the long run Derek it's a
good question
it's stuff in your house that you're not
using
that is true
so a quick question when do we need to
get you the rest of the Ring
there's smoke so when there's smoke
there's fire Derek I love you brother
let's move on to the next one there's
Smokey man thanks
I think I might have to like Beat Bobby
The Brain here I feel like I need to be
a manager and a big event like a Bobby
The Brain human
Slick Rick or
Captain Lou Albano there he is Captain
Lou Captain Lou Captain Lou
Albano if you know what that was I
with you all right let's move on
Diana hey garyvee great to see you again
I um I saw you in 2018
in Brisbane in Australia so yeah you
changed everything for me in terms of
social media and marketing and
completely shifted my understanding of
it after coming out of diploma so thank
you I'm so grateful for everything that
you've shared
um
yeah my question for you today is
um it's for me now that I'm out of the
corporate world and freelancing and I'm
seeing this with a lot of busy business
owners who are wearing so many hats and
I just feel like so many people are
stuck in their startup phase of their
business and I'd love any kind of advice
that you have that can help people like
bridge that gap between that startup
phase and then that next level where you
get to start building a team and start
expanding and growing
what's what's the what's the question
really in that Diana like what's the is
it words of encouragement for people
that feel stuck
I feel like what it is is there's like
uh
a lack of like time potentially because
they're doing so many different things
and I mean but that's what every that's
how Microsoft and Facebook and Tesla and
Walmart and I mean Sam Walton literally
was ringing up people at the register
when he started Walmart
yeah like to me it's a lack of
enjoyment of the early and mud
process that actually people up
they're not in love with their business
they're in love with what they think
they're going to be able to buy for
themselves from the business this is why
we have the greatest era of fake
entrepreneurship right now Diana
okay like what do I what do I say to
people that are in that phase enjoy it
because you'll look back on it as your
favorite time
I mean vaynerx is 2 000 people right now
doing hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue and if I could get into a time
machine and go back to Columbus Circle
and be in buddy media's conference room
with Dave Zhang and Marcus krzastic and
AJ and Sam tagger and just trying to
figure it the out with the dirt and
no Revenue I would do it like this
that's because I love the game
the problem is that most people don't
love the game they're so like they can't
wait to hire you know someone else one
of the reasons Diana that I attack love
your business not what it can buy from
you is do you want to hear a secret
about these people that you're talking
to specifically yeah all of them could
hire somebody right now if they were
willing to have less take-home money
okay
do you know people haven't hired someone
because they'd rather take home a
hundred thousand dollars and buy some
dumb versus taking home fifty five
thousand dollars and not buy dumb
and then hire someone so that they could
take home 200 000 next year they're not
investing in their business they're
investing in their money that they can
buy stuff I'm telling you Diana this is
the big issue yeah people are not
willing to enjoy
the ship fees and stay in it longer
they're in such a rush for the Glam of
it
well
I'm telling you I see it every
day they they want the Ferrari
so bad that they're willing to take too
much money out of the business to buy
the Ferrari to show everyone that
they're successful versus keeping the
money in the business and hiring two
more people
you know
people don't people don't have the
mindset of let me buy the Ferrari
company instead of a Ferrari
they're it's just all short it's all
short most people can afford to hire
someone
sooner than they think it's just that
they don't have the humility to take
less dollars
earlier I mentioned my father never paid
me much he didn't pay himself much
either the money went back into the
business
yeah you know the business wasn't there
for us to buy toys
we were there to feed the business
yeah
I'm grossly underpaid of vaynerx how
about that right now as I sit here with
you right now
why because I'd rather hire more people
and open more offices I'd rather open
the Middle East in Africa in the next
two years than have a couple more
dollars to buy some toy that
means nothing
yeah it's making those choices isn't it
yeah there's people gonna be like Gary
you don't get it toys I'm just
trying to pay rent and have and I'm like
cool
cool do you need a three bedroom house
with two living rooms and a dining room
that you never use in a basement or do
you like it's just choices
choices and I think most people don't
choose their business enough
yeah
um love you gotta get some more thank
you
invest in your business and watch what
your business does for you
hello Gary Juan me out
hey I just got to say thank you so much
for everything you've done your content
your books you've changed not only my
life but lives of people at my church
lives of music schools I've been a part
of everywhere I've gone your ethos of
everything just thank you so much for
everything Gary thank you my brother
so I know you love the New York Jets I
want to talk about Jets not the Jets I
want to talk about private jets I work
in selling private jets and so my niche
of qualified prospects is really really
small a lot of local social media
experts are telling me to make content I
don't like to get more of an audience
because it's it would appeal to more
people to like you know be voyeurs and
look at private jets so my question is
should I cast a wider net even though I
don't enjoy it or keep going deeper with
content that appeal to a small audience
and I really enjoy talking to those
people
yeah I I mean I think I think the
much as a private jet is a wrong mistake
I think that I think that the way the
algorithms work is the content will find
a wider audience
like this concept of cast of wider net I
think you need to talk in more specifics
the the biggest Roi for a private jet
life is time the only people that should
be buying
or renting or using private jets
in real life not I want to be bougie and
show everybody and to close my
insecurity are people that have gotten
to a place where their time is more
valuable than the cost
right I saw that interview you did yeah
I remember mentioning that yes it's real
life like you know it's insane how much
private Aviation costs however luckily
for three
percent of the world they've worked hard
luck of the draw of DNA or circumstance
strategy they work smart hard
combination both they are now in a place
where their time is worth thirty
thousand dollars an hour and all of a
sudden you're like it this is
smarter for me and so to me LinkedIn is
your biggest place for short time yeah I
agree yep I think the other thing you
should do is consider using LinkedIn
to do content that leads to a live event
meaning I would probably do a you know
private jet dinner Series where there
you you do content that leads people to
your website that allows your website to
capture if the person's actually
qualified lead and then you have eight
or seven or six person dinners for
someone that would fit that demo I would
consider doing that because I'd be like
wait a minute there's gonna be seven
other people there that could afford
private Aviation I'm gonna go to this
dinner and hear out Tom if he's a better
option than what I have but I'm also
going to go because I want to meet the
other seven people that are there so I
think content to intimate events is
something people are not doing enough of
especially in high net worth scenarios
mm-hmm and I appreciate that and the
thing with making the content like I
enjoy the nerding out of here's how you
do a pre-buy here's how you choose the
right one here's how the documents work
yeah
you should continue to pound that and by
the way there is no casting a wider net
strategy anymore the algorithms are
finding your audience so you should post
it everywhere but I don't care if you
get seven views on Tick Tock thank you I
agree I agree almost everyone
almost everyone this morning I made that
sound for a fact because I want
everybody to pay attention almost
everyone mainly my team so they clipped
this almost everyone
Tommy right now is making content for
the algorithm not the business outcome
many people now if the business outcome
is brand then I understand the algorithm
but I think people don't understand the
right eyeballs I don't know people yes
watch this show I want the right people
to watch this show thank you why net
here I'm looking for a billion people
you're you're looking at the one percent
of one percent you know three to five
percent that I said earlier is
consideration you know one to one one of
one percent is actual transaction in
your world
yeah no exactly and that's that's kind
of what I keep pushing back on the
social media experts you know listen to
these social enemy experts listen to the
actual social media expert and that's
not even me that's yourself knowing your
if you know your business I appreciate
that hours of learning what I talk about
or people like you don't know then
you're really the actual expert
like it's not about how many followers
you get
it's not about even how many Impressions
you get it's how many Impressions that
matter to what you want
and the more narrow you go with your
content the less views you'll get but
the more narrow the audience will become
and that's actually what you want in
your business so I've been posted
everywhere and I would do best practices
you might as well have the right
thumbnail you might as well write have
the right copy you might as well post at
the right time but you can't have vanity
metrics drive your strategy thank you
thank you Gary so much appreciate it
hey Gary good morning
one second brother Marco my boss Sid
here is trying to whisper something yes
Sid Universal
oh really I'm going I'm at a nice Pace I
think I came with the mindset of going a
little faster so oh Carly's birthday
happy birthday Carly
um
c-a-r-l-y if you want to say happy
birthday in the comments for Carly on
team Gary okay so we are going to
actually potentially have time to
usually we have to push the people but
you're saying we may be able to have a
couple more people potentially and so
212-931-5731 text your question use
hashtag ask I mean tea with garyvee and
the team may jump in and pull one or two
people out live right now this is huge
first time the audience May participate
but we'll see Marco might get me into a
15-minute answer we'll see Marco where
are you from tell us about yourself
I'm from Cartagena Colombia and I'm
actually living
so I'm the founder of a travel concierge
agency called San Felino concierge
started two years back in my hometown I
just moved here with my wife five months
ago through her fellowship and she's
doing Fellowship on Research here so
here's where brother still Colombia or
somewhere else I didn't hear right now
we're in Boston Boston the dirty dirty
dirty Patriots Marco God
damn it all right go ahead
there you go so uh my question is
marketing related and it's
I'm in the luxury travel
industry and we see everyone sort of
doing the same sort of videos of course
you need to show the destination you
need to show but you always see like how
people enhance everything you know like
on social media and it becomes a
standard and videos are great views are
great right but it's all the same so we
really want to go around it differently
and we've been thinking and and I
haven't got to the real answer yet is
how we can go around how we can flip
that in order for not to show the same
you know like the same
the same as everybody else yeah the
same shoes it allows you to break
through and be recognized exactly we
keep the names up the whole time
um so listen brother I think that Marco
I think the thing the question is
when you get clients
do you speak to them ever yeah of course
because we fully customized the triggers
so Marco you know the answer
let me explain
you how many customers have you spoken
to
well 100 so far but uh right yeah
hundreds yeah you know why people pick
you
or why they want it you know the things
that people want or why they buy yes
yeah make content about that yes people
looking for specific things you know
like you wanna like your your
50th birthday you want so you need to
make a video about your party but you
need to make a video that's titled the
perfect trip for your 50th birthday
and you need to speak and then you need
to maybe edit some visuals over it like
you need to become the guy who talks
about the perfect blank the perfect
vacation the three perfect places for a
bachelor party if you make less than
seventy thousand dollars a year you need
to go more specific okay you need to
think back to the 200 300 conversations
you had and why and what they were
looking for and now you need to make
videos talking about that at scale you
need I need to see from you a hundred
videos in the next year a very specific
scenarios
the perfect bachelorette party if you
want to go outside the U.S
the perfect 30th birthday part uh trip
for someone who's wealthy
they're super close like it's a two
hours and a half flight from Miami it's
five hours flight from New York direct
flight every day content brother it's
easy you don't want to make the same
as everyone else don't make the
same as everyone else the problem
is people don't have the courage for it
to not work at first
okay that
this is the theme of the show so far
people are getting by the
algorithm not the way they think where
they're not getting as many views as
they think they deserve based on their
insecurity and ego they're getting
by the algorithm because they're
not making content that's business smart
they're trying to make content that they
think will do well in Social yeah
because really well in Social does not
have a direct correlation to doing well
in business we've already touched on
this twice
yeah of course of course and then if if
I have the time the another question I
had is
in in our industry we have something
that is in financials you're taking
in terms of margin we manage a lot of
money because we have to pay a lot of
vendors right of course I get it also we
take care of everything and it's always
been a discussion an internal discussion
and I and I've tried both ways and I
don't have the answer yet on whether we
should charge or fee and then arrange
for the client to pay to each of the
vendors
you know this both can work you've done
both which one feels better
yeah it it becomes about sometimes with
like doing the additional work doesn't
bring us more margin but it does bring a
big upside for our client because he's
just dealing with us right so it sounds
it sounds like
if you're looking to build long term
and have customer retention
then you're gonna put out the dollars
more often if you're looking for a
shorter term win maybe you don't
I mean both work in this business model
I'm not overly I wouldn't overthink it I
would do whatever you can change your
mind as you already have that there's no
answer to that one they both work in
that model okay what what you need to do
is make content that's specific
right
what's the average cost some people are
asking what's the average cost that they
hit you up
on these trips roughly it really it
really depends but it's the bottom
what's the top give me the whole range
for a trip uh for one week you're
looking somewhere with with uh luxury
accommodations you're looking at five
thousand per person more or less you
know four thousand depending on what you
pick but this is all inclusive uh yeah
or rental
with premium you know like all you can
drink premium drinks uh so if you can
really really put down the alcohol it
might be a good Arbitrage
yeah awesome we're moving on thank you
thank you so much bye
let's keep this going we're tight today
said we got a really
tight show out the gate big shout out to
the twitch Mafia I see all of you in
there keep saying what's up twitch
good morning how are you good where are
you from what do you do
I live in Wilmington Delaware I'm a
hypnotherapist very nice pleasure thank
you so okay I have a question and I feel
like this is perfect the previous post
um the previous I'm sorry I'm nervous
I'm gonna be nervous we're good nothing
there's nothing bad that can happen
everything's how's it in Delaware muggy
like you're like rainy like here but
it's beautiful I love the rain so I'm
happy go ahead okay so I'm feeling
really blocked posting on social media
um especially because I'm a
hypnotherapist and I'm concerned that
the things I feel really aligned posting
aren't professional enough because I
know that you know there are a lot of
misperceptions around hypnosis so I'm so
concerned about being so professional
and I think it's really blocking me from
authentically posting content
um
yeah so what do I do because can I ask
you a question is this about is this
about people's subjective opinions or is
this about rules that you have to stay
Within
uh within the category of work that you
do I think it's more about people's
opinions but that's what I thought thank
God because that game maybe I can
hypnotize you right now ready okay let's
not three times and you're gonna
understand the following
you are no longer in high school in
junior high
and people making fun of you no longer
matters okay okay so let me tell you
this like I had breast cancer and so
things that I speak about you know are
about my body and right sometimes my
breasts come up and things like that so
I'm just worried that I don't know if
you heard it's 20 23.
like breasts are like the most mundane
like and you're coming from a medical
place on this
I'm very empathetic and I love you for
being respectful but but you're not
trying to do quadruple x porn no you're
trying to help people yeah who are in
the same challenging situation that
you're in you're doing God's work you're
not trying to do something wrong and
there's nothing wrong by the way with
that like let people be
yeah like like I I think you're looking
at this wrong I'm empathetic to why
you're looking at this way yeah but I
hope you're on here for permission to do
what you know you should be doing
because that's what I sense I think you
know the answer
you're trying intent matters Ramona
your intent is to help people who are in
an incredibly challenging situation
you're a gift not a curse
yeah
yeah so for yeah so for businesses it's
okay you know it's okay to post
free-spirited things I'm just I'm just
so I I've been posting the same stuff
you were talking about posting the same
crap that everyone else is posting I
feel like that's where I'm stuck because
you post what you want
yeah what do you think's gonna happen
I'm just worried that people won't take
me seriously that I'm not professional
you know that I'm because you're talking
about science
but I mean I post other things too not
just about the cancer Journey you know
as you should I put I'm a real
businessman and I post about all sorts
of dumb garage tailing the Jets
like like I don't give a that
people don't take me serious I care
about the results I'm happy and
successful yeah
but what like I'm telling you you're
stuck in high school
okay like so they don't take you serious
you give a I'm look let me look
here you give a if Dustin doesn't
take you serious or Jared B over here in
backstage you think you give actual
if he doesn't take you serious
that's not
on you that's on him
yeah
okay
yeah so yeah okay I've just been feeling
so blocked so this you've been locked
because you know everyone feels blocked
when they overvalue other people's
opinions over their own happiness
yeah true
you know like like
I mean
I mean the support you're getting in the
comments right now is outrageous
you have to look yeah watch this I have
a great idea can everybody please how
many followers do you is this your
answer let's well I got a great idea
we're gonna do something really smart
here I'm just starting out so nobody's
judging you and then don't worry I don't
give a if you have one follower
you have you have 599 followers right
that's my personal account and I feel
free posting on there but then when it
comes to my business oh so we're not
posting where we want to go to a
different account
on my what's your what's your business
account that you're worried about we're
about to change your life here watch
what's about to happen what's what's the
account on that one it's rora hypnosis
I can't spell hypnosis it's been my
bio the link to it
there we go you've got 245 followers
right Justin please put up that or I
have no idea how I actually spelled that
properly I'm very happy with myself okay
you have 245 followers right and you're
worried about what people are gonna
think right
right like that's what we're talking
about
right yeah so right now what we're going
to do is we're going to double your
following with all these nice people
everybody I really need you to do this
Dustin it's not very clear here like
that's too small I can't even see that
can you put big the handle at the handle
please dust can you produce yeah thank
you like this I can't even see
this like big dust like do it right big
at right down here that makes it very
easy for people like very very easy can
everybody please share right now this
hat or uh hip
that's right p and
thank you so what here's what we're
doing right like all right I did that
wrong by the way
um you were at 2 45 you're now at 397.
right which means now you're at 405.
so right now you just doubled it and now
more than your hat more than half the
people
that follow you on this account you're
now at 446 you're gonna you've now
basically next minute we'll have more
followers than that are new than you had
prior to this call okay
you now have 500 followers you now have
more followers of nice people here
who care for you and want you to win
because you're part of this beautiful
Community then you had
all prior to this moment do you know
what that means that means you should
feel 100 free
to post whatever the you want and I
need your next two posts to really come
from your heart and be like what you're
about you're now at 660 followers oh my
gosh thank you Gary
but if you want to thank me I
desperately desperately desperately need
you
to post freely because now you have what
you have 726 you have 500 more followers
literally tooth you barely have you have
like two-thirds of your followers are
now new on this account
and all loving people they're not on
this show if they're not the right type
like your community now is like pure
yeah
okay oh my gosh thank you so much
gratitude to you I appreciate it thank
you see ya right Laura should not be
scared anymore said but that's not gonna
happen for all of you what just happened
that was a moment in time now she's up
to 800 followers that's a moment in time
that's not gonna happen for that what we
have to all learn is we can't worry
about people's opinions we need to come
from our intent and our heart and let
the chips fall when I started my journey
in business world people told me I was
too casual I cursed unacceptable I
didn't wear a suit unacceptable the
world came to me not I came to the world
I just lived my truth in 2006 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 and then eventually
things changed you guys have to live
your truth not what you think the world
is requiring for you let's keep it going
hey Gary how are you good brother how
are you
I'm doing real well thank you uh my
question is two parts it's actually not
so much about social media or uh growing
a brand or anything like that um it's a
it's a post covid question so I own a
couple businesses and uh so my question
is what is your view of the labor force
mentality post covet that's the first
part
well I think Joaquin I think most
people's work ethic has been altered by
the fact that we
work at home at a high percentage which
creates a lot of opportunity to hide if
one wants to the government sent checks
to everybody so people got used to wait
a minute like I can get paid to stay at
home you have an entire generation of
Gen X what Millennials and Z who grew up
in a different era and different eras so
they have different mindsets in them
within Generations you have very
different people so you can't generalize
but overall I think that we haven't
flushed out the economic pain of
printing so much money during covid and
so it's we're in this weird place where
half the workforce is entitled and half
the workforce realizes that they have an
opportunity to gain market share by
working hard and it's a real mix and
everyone's situation is different but if
I'm talking net Network Force it's a
little tricky right now and we're going
to feel pain from that because
businesses are not as efficient you know
there's plenty of people that work their
ass off from home but there's enough
that don't that the efficiencies of
businesses and what they're paying for
are down and so we're in an interesting
spot like we're we're gonna hits
the fan moment in 24 25 26 where we're
gonna have to reset and so you know I
think it's a wild mix you know
yeah I I do agree um my businesses
aren't really work from home Skype I'm
in the hospitality industry
um so for me I need I need bodies you
know I need Cooks I need servers I need
Barista and as you know not only not
only has that mentality shifted a lot of
these cooks and servers now know how to
make more money online so it's not just
the missteps of the governments Around
The World of Printing more money during
covid and not letting people live within
their means because all those CH you
know think about the reason we're having
all this fluctuation is we send all this
money to people and they went out and
bought Dom perion and you know right you
know Chanel not food and electricity and
so but also let's not let's not be
confused in the hospitality business
there's a lot of people that have
figured out how to make more money
online flipping stuff on eBay or being
coming influencers and creators that
make them more than 20 bucks an hour 15
bucks an hour 12 bucks an hour 25 bucks
an hour and so you know as they have
more options they are going to choose
those options
yeah I totally agree when when I um you
know I asked always you know in the
interview again tell me about yourself
and the majority of the you know the
Barista age demographic they want to be
influencers and they want to be
YouTubers you know and so it's super
hard for a restaurant
well there's a way for you to flip it
though why don't you start hiring and
put a help wanted sign that says help
wanted influencer Creator slash Barista
then people come in they're like what
the is that and you're like listen
yeah you're while you're at the stand
you know the host the host this while
you're working you're nine to five you
can use my restaurant as your content
Studio
you know most employers are like get off
your phone you could flip it and
be like hey you've got this whole
restaurant as your production facility
you're gonna get paid and as long as
you're taking care of my customers and
doing what I need to do operational
every time there's downtime make
content maybe tag the location go ahead
that's the balance is like I think we've
lost a lot of work ethic I agree with
that because we do that already ideology
this is I talked to my dad about
with Wine Library that's an ideology
everything I said is true but I'm not
emotional about it I don't need people
to work on I don't give a I don't
care what my feelings are about how much
money we gave people or why they have
better options or that we've lost work
or gen Z is into I don't give a I'm
a businessman so what I'm going
to deal with is the reality of the
situation and if I have to change the
way I operate my restaurant my
dad's liquor store my I'm opening a
restaurant in a month in New York City
with wecr group called little Maven in
Midtown and a couple months later we're
opening up the fly fish Club I've got
tons of restaurants in my world coming
right and what I'm telling my partners
who are operating is leave your old
ideologies at the desk because
it's a new world and if we and if and if
the like it's also practical you know
this brother I don't want the hostess or
host or I don't want the Barista or I
don't want the waiter to be making
content while Sid or you are sitting
there frustrated but when there's down
time like if we have a lull if there's a
mid-afternoon LOL it's better that
they're making content for you I
understand that they go viral and quit
because then you can use them as an
example for the next person
I would have them in the I would
be like be like at Sally pants49 be like
Barista 16 be like Barista boy
nine I would put them in my job
description to get people excited that
they found a boss and an environment to
make content that allows them to go live
their dream
yeah I know where I mean we're doing
that now Mike my question is more uh on
the on like the mindset of yeah you're
right okay so you're right with front of
the house I agree with that let's talk
about Cooks
right like you can't necessarily always
have your cook while plating pulling out
his phone or filming this okay bro right
hear me out if you create hard rules
that are like hey any moment of downtime
that does not affect the customer's
timing
yeah changes the game yeah yeah or or
you have to change your business model
if books are more expensive expensive
because nobody wants to be a cook well
we are all going to pay more for food
you're not the only one dealing with
this no no yeah I agree with you this is
where people don't get it where like
they're like oh we got to do it for this
cool but it all then comes down to you
know our costs and by the way
we're only 15 years away from hooks
being robots
yeah yeah
you know yeah that's the challenge
really is where do you find like the
work ethic and to pay someone what
they're worth because I'm gonna help you
on something that I can sense
okay you will be in a total
of your idea geology at the door
okay there's unlimited people that are
willing to work hard in gen Z
but if you decided that they're all
entitled or nobody wants to be a cook
then you're dead because you're spending
energy on that it doesn't matter how you
and I came up it was a different world
you and I would have not come up this
way if we had this world and guess what
our great grandparents came up harder
than us of course so I don't want to
hear 2023 bosses crying about
well 20 years ago we added it's over
charge more change it up pay your Cooks
more you know which then pass on the
cost to me let me pay 25 cents more for
an orange juice and let me spend an
extra two dollars on steak like it's
just real life pass on the cost to the
consumer yeah everybody in New
York wanted the Uber drivers to get you
know more money cool let me just tell
you what's happening all the Uber
deliveries are way more expensive for
food
yeah yeah that's what's happening here
it's not like it's gonna just I love
when people are like yeah Stick it to
the business it's
gonna happen you're gonna pay for it
yeah exactly so I think you've got a lot
of moves brother
I but I think the number one move you
need to start with is don't give a
it is what it is
how many cooks do you need
Real Talk uh
no I need probably 11. good I promise
where do you live
uh Miami Florida
I promise on my everything
that you can find 11 Cooks you just need
to go ham with content indeed LinkedIn
you just need to hustle
yeah it's it's just different you know I
mean you hire I'm sure you hire it's
just the mindset is so different that
it's yeah you're emotional you're
emotional it's different eight out of
ten
somebody just immigrated to Miami just
now just a second who will rip
their arm off to be a cook for you
I agree with that okay so instead of
crying you know dwelling spending your
energy being like like every minute
that you spend talking to your buddy or
another guy who or gal who owns a
restaurant be like every
second
could be a second of you making content
on the internet
or or hanging up signs in lower income
areas to pull you want to like you like
your work ethic needs it up
yeah
fair enough right you know I I love how
you took that like that's on us no I
like buck stops with me you know that's
the truth and and it's like you know so
we post on Instagram we post on indeed
uh here let me just throw this out if I
this is a great example because this
happened last week if I fill out in an
indeed format and then I accept 27 Cooks
to come in to interview how many of
those 27 cooks that confirm their
interview time do you think actually
come in seven
it's left like four okay so and then out
of those but okay
yeah bro you don't think I know my dad
is ripping his two last hairs
out of his head getting stock guys at
Wine Library I've got people like
Vader's different because just like
everybody wants to be in social media so
we're on the other side of this we have
unlimited people applying but I'm
involved in a billion businesses and I'm
on the boards and stuff and I'm watching
the economy and I follow youth culture
and immigrant culture and and and Boomer
cult I watch the world I know what
you're dealing with
yeah the problem is get 97 people to
apply you need 11 books right yeah yeah
and honestly the numbers game right by
the way is indeed the right place to get
Cooks because indeed's a bougier place
that probably leads to people not
showing up I think you need to go
to a strip in a lower yeah
that's exactly Craigslist and brother if
I'm using nope no
no
give me one second
like if I'm you I make this sign
right all right yeah how many
Kinkos and make a million copies and I
literally me myself Joaquin Ortiz go to
lower income strip malls around Miami
and put them in the cars
put them on the dust stop like it
let's go you're in control yeah I hear
you I know you can do this you can get
11. by doing this not fancy
yeah heard that my man cool love you all
right appreciate your time thank you
great first episode of tea with garyvee
I'm really happy I got some
entrepreneurial tactics out like
make a sign like that's how you
do it and walking you felt it like I
loved him on that like everybody I
really hope you enjoyed this episode I
enjoy doing it we're back with details
and information both in the macro and
the micro this shows macro micro we
started with mindset we ended with dirt
tactic and everything in between that is
the truth of how this game is played do
not get caught up in your ideologies
we'll see you shortly when we back next
week should we we'll find something next
week we'll be back next week we'll
promote it please share out the link of
this show as soon as it ends it becomes
a YouTube show I'd love for you to go to
Twitter take the URL of this share it
and tell everybody your favorite part
I'll retweet five or six for promotion
and awareness of tea with garyvee it's
back we'll see you next time